LifeNet health is proud to introduce
preserve on a proprietary glycerol based
preservation solution that has distinct
advantages over conventional bio implant
preservation methods preserve on is an
ambient temperature preservation method
that saves valuable part I'm and allows
bone to remain hydrated thus preserving
bio mechanical strength allograft bio
implants processed using the preserve on
technology retain the same functional
performance of bio implant tissue
processed using conventional methods
in addition preserve untreated allograft
bio implants do not need to be
rehydrated or fraud prior to
implantation unlike typical frozen
allograft bio implant products that
require special storage and shipping
preserve on allows storage at ambient or
room temperature conditions preserve on
reduces the lengthy rehydration time
associated with freeze-dried allograft
issue since bio implants are provided
fully hydrated using preserve on
eliminates the need for freeze drying
which may be associated with decreased
allograft bio implant integrity and
compared to bio implants processed using
conventional methods preserve on
maintains its biochemical properties
preserve on maintains compressive
strength to that of bone processed using
conventional methods
the allograft bio implant is immersed
into the preserve on solution the
glycerol molecules in the preserve on
solution are designed to replace the
freestanding water content of the bone
matrix surface while the collagen fibers
retain water molecules the solution is
then drained from the chamber
next the allograft bio implant is
centrifuged to remove excess glycerol
the allograft bio implant is now ready
for packaging and can be stored at an
ambient temperature for implantation at
a later date preserve on the future of
allograft
bio implant preservation